welcome it's that time of the month
again the day which I had another shoot
earlier in the day and had my makeup
done for it so I'm gonna double down and
do this shoot in my own home right now
I'd you till I saw makeup that a
professional put on my face no high
mater's burger which is different now
welcome to another episode I'm cooking
you're watching it's happening not a
good title that's right hello fresh has
consistently refused to abandon their
support of me as a creator on this
platform what's that I can hear you
talking are you talking about points are
you talking point and if you don't know
what hello fresh is they are America's
number one meal kit you can get seasonal
recipes with pre measured ingredients
delivered right to your door and all you
do is cook and eat to the best of your
ability which is what I'm testing out
today here are the talking points that I
left out the first time that I recorded
this video guess what you can break out
of your dinner rut with their 17
seasonal chef's curated recipes each
week and you can add extra meals to your
weekly order as well as yummy sides or
desserts like garlic bread and cookie
dough here's what I got this much pork
and veggie bib amass and even being back
even Baba that pork teriyaki meatball
and a Juicy Lucy burger we got some
great options this month but I'm leaning
into something I've never ever made
before
pork teriyaki meatballs she's beautiful
with carrots and zucchini over rice me
directly in the end this is going to be
really good and I'm very excited and I
know I'm gonna feel slightly
accomplished afterwards and that makes
me a little nervous
so oh I had a drink before we started
all the meals come with a recipe card
that has six steps with the visual aids
everything that you need for your recipe
comes prepackaged and pre-measured for
you they treat you like a toddler and
that's the only thing I want for
everyone in the universe in everything I
do all the time this says prep time is
ten minutes
the total time is 35 minutes and you
know it I love to prove people wrong in
this six step recipe card the built-in
drinking game here right now to yourself
or your loved one significant other
friend enemy that you are currently in a
physical space with make a guess on
which step once or six that I will never
leave shop and you know if you get it
right you drink if you get it wrong you
drink wrong fun let's make some pork
teriyaki meatballs everything comes in
here
no eggs that's how you test if there's
an egg in there and some ground pork
alright I just got overwhelmed thing
Depp number one wash and dry all produce
trim and half a zucchini lengthwise
slice crosswise into thin half moon you
again need to be cleaned are you happy
now this is what my life is becoming
went to college none just screaming at
zucchini we're getting up where are you
going I know I shamed you but I need you
we trim slice crosswire which I guess is
this and now we cut these into Halfmoon
shapes amazing now we peel and miss the
ginger the thing it looks like some sort
of like petrified critter turd it's
ginger we're gonna put it in our body
we're gonna peel it I must weenie one
thumb what this measurement of how much
ginger we need is one thumb does that
mean my thumb well I'm just gonna peel
into him I'm gonna assume that that
means basically around the size of like
a human thumb okay so the ingredients
say that you have a thumb worth of
ginger but the directions say that you
need a tablespoon
it's a tablespoon ginger away now we
need to quarter our line wonderful and
now we're gonna track these scallions
and separate the greens from the why I
get so bored kind of cooks do it this is
like so bored and also therapeutic and
rewarding and I love it the hello fresh
sponsors me there we go
step one officially done you know what
that means I'm drinking a beer like I'm
a girl next door
that's gross beer tastes like you drank
carbonated soil Cheers step two form the
meatballs and cook the rice in a medium
bowl you're going to
buying the pork Oh 1/4 cup of panko
breadcrumbs
Wow I made a mess ginger remember we
have so many members together a
tablespoon of teriyaki sauce and then we
season with some pepper then we form
these into 1-inch balls I mean this
smells great which is usually not
something you say around balls I'm gonna
pour mousse into 1-inch balls in a
second because I'm gonna cook the rice
in the meantime in a small pot we're
gonna combine the race and 1 and 1/4 cup
of water or the big pinch of salt we're
gonna bring it to a boil and cover and
reduce heat to low and then cook until
tender for 15 to 18 minutes pinch
yourself we bring that to a boil we have
been to step 2 time for step 3 you know
what that means I hate you it's time to
cook the zucchini all the rice cooks
we're gonna take a medium pan we're
gonna put some oil in it I'm gonna put
our zucchini and it with some salt and
the pepper and we're gonna cook it for
like four to six minutes so Oh we're
gonna let our zucchini cook for four to
six minutes in the meantime I'm gonna
roll out some meatballs and then we're
gonna take the zucchini out of the pan
and then end up putting these meatballs
in the pan okay Wow I have formed some
balls
our zucchini is basically done so we're
gonna transfer that to a medium bowl
time to cook the meatballs and what time
to cook the carrots and sear the
meatballs here we go the same pan that
we just took the zucchini out we're
gonna put another drizzle of olive oil
in and put our carrots in and season
with salt and pepper
oh we're gonna cook those for three to
four minutes stirring until tender up I
love being stirred up until intended the
carrots have been covered through the
four minutes gonna transfer them to a
bowl with the zucchini now we are going
to oh I read ahead so we're gonna take
our bulb zucchini and carrots and we're
gonna toss with half we're gonna toss
with half of this estimate oil that
we've been given yeah now in that same
pan that we just took carrots that we're
gonna heat another large drizzle of oil
and the burger add the meatballs we're
gonna cook turning consistently for
about four to six minutes until browned
all
okay look ah I guess Jamie and also I
got fully hypnotized by turning my balls
[Music]
that got away from me next step we're
gonna add the remaining teriyaki sauce
with henna meatballs are gonna bring to
a simmer and reduce the heat to
medium-low I'm sorry very drinking him
so far I haven't oh right do not rinse
well and our meatballs continue to cook
up as if you don't have a lid you can
cover the pan with aluminum foil which I
just did well we've also contained the
cook five to seven minutes the wrench
off the heat and never under finish and
serve you know her gonna do the meantime
no in the meantime Oh time for talking
points if you guys don't know by now you
can get started with eight free meals
that's eight dollars off your first
month you look fresh calm and use the
promo code great pelvic eighty I want
this food so bad right now in my mouth
and that's how I do foreplay also do you
know what my gastrointestinal system is
bonkers I have Nick Oh also well
sentence $6.99 per serving
I got it in before the okay okay this is
basically done so we're gonna finish and
serve which means we're gonna fluff the
rice with a fork stir in the remaining
sesame seed oils we use a little bit of
live to tape then top of veggies and
meatballs and drizzle with the remaining
sauce as much sriracha has been like and
topped with sesame seeds and scallion
greens and the remaining live which is
on the side so get ready so technically
this entire meal is made for two people
but I'm gonna put together a big old one
dish beauty shot
[Music]
this is when she shows up to the bar and
then someone like playfully suggest a
Rumple Minze shot and then she does it
and then the rest of the night is haha
laughs time to here we go oh gosh oh
gosh oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh stop I
truly thought I put this one up and you
tell me I did it everyone to inform you
that I did a good job again me that's
really good
I guess I'm perfect this is fantastic I
just made a bowl of good thank God
oh we did again thank you guys so much
for watching this video if you liked
they give it a thumbs up other than that
I make videos I don't know I got tired
because I was posing for a thumbnail
which is the worst sentence
I think anyone's ever said ever